the other question I have is and and
this is funny cuz I treated about this
and a bunch people got really really mad
like it's really triggered these lefties
I asked legitimately why are so many
anti-fascist furries yeah I saw that
tweet but III didn't mean I'm not
disparaging actually asking I know it's
a legitimate question there's like a
really high-profile cartoon squirrel
that's constantly daxing people and
harassing people okay with like tons of
followers mm-hm and there's a bunch of
furries with first they're called first
zone as I think yeah like they're their
avatar is their self designed art of
themself as a cartoon animal hey man
look I'm all about Liberty so I don't
care if you're a furry let me do
whatever you want man you know you'll be
part of clown playing you know blame
it's the parents they're bad parents a
lot of these young parents give their
kids iPads here here you go and then
what do they watch they watch cartoons
so they grow up idolizing cartoons
instead of their parents instead of
having parents that they look well
through they're like wow I want to be
like that person they watch and are
raised by cartoons and they see they see
anthropomorphised animals yep as society
right so ingrain isn't that person
honestly not that surprising yeah but
that's not my age it's sad that's not my
issue isn't that people are furry I
don't care no no I know I just I'm just
making notes like hmm why just noticed
that why are they an taifa oh I don't
know somebody they want purpose
apparently there are like white
supremacist furries okay I was like a
big thing I guess random but okay yeah
and they weren't they have like they
have nazi armbands but it's a paw print
instead of a swastika or whatever I'm
not I'm not kidding dude I don't know I
don't know if it's a joke or whatever
I'm just pointing it out so if I see the
the paw print I don't know what what it
means now I don't know what it means
Thanks yeah I have no idea I've actually
never seen a furry before no but
somebody made a good point and they said
it's that the the the left has
successfully made it so that in many
communities like gaming movies even in
the furry community yeah you can't be
conservative huh because of canceled
culture and the fear that they'll attack
you so these people just shut up and
then the and then what you end up seeing
is all of this an tyfa but doesn't
really explain it it doesn't explain how
like
I don't know I don't know like I don't
know what this is but there's a bunch of
these like characters and I'm not saying
these people are furries but there
actually are some hi perfect I don't use
their real names like I don't want to
cause a brigade or anything but there's
like some people that are actually
well-known verified furries who are like
very vocal about supporting an Tifa I'm
like what's that all about somebody
mentioned like a lot of the
right-wingers have like avid like anime
avatars and I'm like that's not really
true either it's like an eagle and like
an American flag yeah like I don't know
I don't know you or like a kak you know
pet frog or something it's like I don't
I do see anime people but that really
it's usually like these tumblr ena
leftists use use anime stuff yeah but
they're not dressing up as the
characters are they they're not like
full-on outfits no certain size no I
mean like all of these people oh right
right I mean that will they'll wear
their like American flag hat and like
sure Trump shirt or whatever or like
Trump hat yeah okay that's not like
embodying a different animal though
that's that's myth isn't that what furs
do they like getting the full outfit I
don't yeah it's a fur suit yeah yeah
like really expensive like a crazy
lifestyle apparently they've like tried
to have conventions but the people are
just like nuts and we're like sabotaging
plumbing or something I don't know
somebody somebody posted response like
here's your understanding and I watch
this video and it was really weird I
think I look I don't care what you do
with your life and your free time you
know that's why I'm like I'm not even
it's not even really about furries at
all it's about an taifa yeah and and
what it is one of the responses I got
from a lot of people was that they're an
taifa are mentally ill people you know
it's like we talked about with the Joker
the other day you know that this fringe
ideology needs allies so it seeks out
vulnerable you know unstable individuals
to support it just like I said earlier
like I read that article
auntie Fez is going to high schools and
and colleges looking for the people that
are outcasts and are that don't fit into
society and they're snatching them up
because what you do is you tell them the
reason you don't fit in yeah Trump yeah
because because Society yeah it's
society's fault everyone else
it's everyone else's fault yeah exactly
it's not your fault it's I'm here for
you all right it's not your fault
and how do we actually deal with that
you know like what do you do do you like
drop them in the middle of woods mega
mega learn how to survive or some came
on a camping trip what did their parents
do wrong
they weren't parents yes simple they
were gone it's that they weren't parents
they dude you know that all I see is is
as they get older and older to looking
at the kids like oh that's just kids
being kids they'll get up they'll grow
over that they'll get out of that face
eventually I think and they don't try
they don't they don't engage they just
like yeah whatever whatever I think it
just runs rampant I think it's the
logical logical conclusion of what we've
been seeing over the past hundred years
mm-hmm
it used to be and I think you brought
this up a few days ago that you were a
blacksmith and then your kid would watch
and learn and help you in the shop and
that eventually became a blacksmith too
yeah and then you got really good at
blacksmithing yeah and that was a family
you know a family name it was your
family job then we had apprenticeships
and then it was like not just your kid
it was also other people would come and
pick trades and then it eventually
became stuff all the kids in a factory
yeah parents go Avenue in every job in
kids or shoveling coal into a you know a
steam engine or something mm-hmm but
then we started putting them in schools
institutional institutionalized learning
facilities with the bells that you know
I've heard it's supposed to simulate
factories I know that's true
we're like the bell rings the period no
uh yeah but you slowly take the parents
away from the kids eventually the kids
are mindless drones they don't know what
they are right now it is companies don't
want college kids anymore right a lot of
them don't yeah because they're not
experienced they their heirs are
clueless all right I have my degree okay
do this job well what do you what do you
need me to do this job can you do it or
not
no I you have to tell me what to do
can't you hold my hand show me what
about my homework my professor you know
what work is my professor told me what
to do okay yeah my professor would tell
me what I had to do and like okay bro I
I don't know how to do that job that's
why I hired you yeah yeah I've literally
experienced this where I'm like um you
know I hired someone to pacifically to
manage
accounting when I was working for a
fusion mm-hmm and they're like asking me
like what do I do much I don't know
that's why I have a hard time with with
anyone building stuff for me because I
have a really high standard for the way
I build stuff you know whatever it is
you know if it's a bedroom you know even
running the electric unless it's like a
professional person doing it I want to
do it myself because I know how to do it
and I'd rather it done right because if
it isn't done right I'm just gonna have
to do it myself these kids aren't good
at anything
you know they've got no skills they are
talentless blobs of nothing you know and
now they're angry that they don't get
all of these things they can't they
can't make themselves or they can't earn
well it's no wonder that they're angry
because they were told their whole lives
they can do anything they want anything
you dream of you can do but you don't
have to work for it I'm just gonna keep
telling you you can do anything it's
like yeah you could do anything but you
have to pick one thing and then go for
that for a long time and then eventually
you get new it the problem is the
previous generation demanded we go to
college hmm like like [ __ ] lemmings yep
marching up it's a requirement now yeah
I remember when I was little my man I
tell you what my family had been telling
me to go to college non-stop my whole
life I was like nope nope never gonna
happen never gonna happen and then one
of the funniest things happen was after
I got I got featured in TIME's Person of
the Year and the time 100 I actually had
family be like so are you gonna go to
college and I was like why is it a joke
he's not seen me in the time magazine I
was like I I've been invited to speak at
a PhD course on journalism you've been
to the White House man yeah it's pretty
cool that that was like I'm 30 how about
34 when that happened no 33 yeah
whatever
so but I'm talking about like I'm 26 I
have a career I'm being like feature and
and and I have these professors saying
like this technique is incredible and
they're asking me to come and give guest
lectures at my colleges at colleges and
I still had family being like you really
need to go to college now and I'm like
are you insane yeah why go to college
but you think about that pressure even I
was getting from my family and you think
about all these kids who don't know
better and I can't you know I don't I
don't completely blame them
if you were told your whole life you can
have everything you want so long as you
play by these rules
here's do you have to do no cheating
allowed go to school go to high school
get a loan go to college and they
graduate and they're told
actually you're an indentured servant
for the rest of your life yeah I'm not
surprised they're freaking out
yeah is one of the reasons why I'm very
much in favor of college debt
forgiveness but I don't believe we
should just do with like what Warren
said or whatever and just write a blank
check Yeah right here's 50 grand boom
just hand it out no I think we should
just terminate the interest rates yeah
yeah I like that so you've got to pay
down everything you've spent yeah you
you got pay for because the professor's
still gonna get paid the college no
these are people out of school no okay
okay yeah yeah but now they owe money
afterwards after the so they got a loan
from a company the company put a
percentage you know uh you know interest
rate on it right cuz it's all just the
bank's then making that interest anyway
we have a predatory system yeah yeah
that is it is creating an entire
generation of whiney Communists so I'm
not I'm not gonna as much as I can
complain about the manual I laugh but
you're right yeah listen man they get a
school and they were told look you're 18
you'd think this 18 year old you know
chick or whatever who's like I'm in the
occupied you know free zone or whatever
you think just any idea what's gonna
happen when the next which is 68 years
of her life zero clue exactly you take
it you take a kid who's in high school
who's you know naive ignorant not saying
stupid just inexperienced and you say
trust us we're your adults you have to
do these things it's no surprise many of
these people are trying to throw all of
out the window because the system is
broken and they were lied to
the solution isn't communism though the
solution is walk out to the middle the
feelings are growing your own corn and
building your own Hut youhave your own
path find your own way but I can't say
I'm surprised I want to burn it all down
just like you said it uh what was it
occupy when they gave them a farm yeah
like what do you do it look you guys
want to try it here's a farm there you
go we gave you a farm and what happened
okay they lasted like 2 weeks like but I
don't like doing work wait a minute I
have to work it's a work to live mine do
yes kidding life is not easy but think
about it you I know a lot of people and
I've asked I've talked to people about
this and they've told
like I've have had friends and this was
back you know 10 or so years ago like
super depressed saying I did everything
right
I did everything they said was the right
thing to do and by the time I graduated
and I have a degree there's no jobs yeah
I've got $40,000 in debt I can't pay it
off so it's deferring and now the
interest is going up and it's gonna be
60 thousand by the time actually find a
job this is ridiculous yeah and I'm like
what you hear from a lot of people as
well you took the loan that's your fault
you're an adult and I'm like I agree
with that within reason I would agree
with that on the individual level if
you're an individual you can't blame
anyone but yourself yeah but on a mass
scale we have an entire system churning
out whiny communists you got to realize
it's gonna rip our our country apart at
the seams
yeah like so being it it's actually
having in front of our eyes right now
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you